hello and welcome to this rapid game
2510 playing Frank 216 this is China
okay yeah probably getting a classical
opening here okay we have the Italian
game yeah I'm not yet their worst in the
two nights defense I want to learn that
when I can't lay their opening in the
odd game but have to be a honest there
it's not that i know it in good enough
detail castle see I castles is an
interesting move it shows that there are
a couple of ideas one idea is to play a
quick d phi n this position after Knight
f6 deform a gambit line now I can avoid
that which d6 it's let's play d 6 the
drawback is that heap can play C 3
Knight f6 d for now it's not so a
problem or anything but it is some know
it is the theoretical drawback of the 46
line d takes d5 now is a pretty boring
continuation so let's hope let's hope I
don't get that
yeah it's 20 5 10 25 minute base time
and ten second increment / move enough
time to explain the ins and outs of the
game properly Cain so Bishop to g5 so I
think I guess age 6 cm I have to play
that move anyway sooner or later to do
something about that pin had to be
perfectly honest I'm not quite sure what
he does now if he takes on f6 Bishop g5
was completely misguided and if he goes
to age form well I can probably go g5g
five Bishop g3 and maybe even though i
take c form it seems playable to me at
the moment I'm not sure why I shouldn't
take the big paw down okay if he goes it
can also think about the peace sacrifice
of course but I don't see how that would
work out so let's go g5 he can take e
five now but d take c5 I can even take
the bishop de 5 GTA is aged for e five
f6 Queen f6 and this is excellent for
black with the open G file and my pieces
so active yeah that's simply incorrect
that's just an incorrect move we have
not cathode this is quite important so
what is he going to do I think when rook
g8 is the group GM g 8 is the normal way
to two
check out this
there anything else that I can that I
can do
rg8 is right it basically wins a wins a
temple on the on the bishop if he goes
f4 i will take t4 and I'm threatening
then to take on c3 with the discover
check pretty awful
yeah maybe he goes age 41 possible way
to play then is just to take on g5 it's
not the best move I think but it's
something that quite often it is an easy
easy option teach you 5h takes Knight g4
the other move is root g 6 and this is
what I'm going to do covering the night
from there from the side and preparing a
clean move so that I can can a pin queen
f 3 i'll just take on deform
h5 then putting the bishop hangs there
is really no compensation that
sacrifices completely incorrect on g5 it
is sometimes interesting of course to
give the piece therefore the two pawns
but normally um the defending side has
to have castles at least and without the
King on g8 it's it's very rarely very
rarely working
yeah I wonder what is he what is he
coming up with him difficult to even
develop something like 92 well just
probably take the pawn I could have
played Bishop g4 as well just recognize
that may well not clear hmm okay yeah I
don't mind dad I don't my dad free
pretty nice my bishop on b6 now gets to
be great I just wonder where to go e 7
is making quite some sense just them
unpinning this way yeah it is good I
think along here ideas simple now nah
def let the F move the F night can move
they have six night and then I go we
have 6 10 6 and the game over also e4 is
just hanging now yeah that's a pretty
big one actually if I can take the
central pawn just like that are we
pretty awful
you should be five chick I just go to f8
some completely completely save him
yeah d5 wasn't it wasn't the most
testing move but every didn't see
anything great then one additional thing
is that once i get that pin sort it out
I have a pretty big attack yeah Ted
Bishop won't be 6g file is open I bishop
c8 is ready to join you to age three
something like that okay so Bishop g4
it's not clear why it's pretty good
actually why not Bishop g4 yeah if he
goes Quincy three I can play Queen to d7
intending Knight takes e4 and night h5
yeah Queen d7 [ __ ] Stadium covering g4
so that i can take a for next or night
h5
yeah also casalino this seems to be on
the cards but i don't i don't know if i
still need that maybe I do yeah so
that's just for one moment think here if
I have something better I will discover
a yellow with the bishop which nothing
nothing wrong with this
okay so he's out for f3
yummy
ok anyway let's get the final piece into
the game the rook here yeah Bishop h5 if
I did not want to play that move but I
maybe have to yeah I probably don't have
to but the sacrifices don't look so
convincing and I can also just a tech
with with all the pieces I don't need to
sacrifice tough Luke GA it comes next
and then it won't be long until all
pieces are joining this attack on his
skin
the other world it will be pretty pretty
tough enter Luke g8 coming and then
there are possible sacrifice on f3
already but let's see what he what he
does this one ok so route g8 he might
play we near three and trade queens yeah
okay that's not the most exciting thing
to do but anyway so he is indeed trading
Queen so but check right just play that
position so 96 to f4
you can also take without the Queen's
it's possible okay so check on that form
yep Jack guess so so if I if I give it
back on g4 there is no way how is
preparing a protecting the age for porn
so let's do that it will be the quickest
way to do it just attack with with all
those pieces bishop on b6 night on f4
and the rooks the biggest threat she is
rook f2 age six and then takes on edge
for inmate I don't even see how he
prevents that to be honest my cannot
really group f 6 h-6 it's pretty pretty
deadly or look f6 g6 alternatively yeah
this one made next I mean you can
sacrifice some stuff to to delay it but
it will be made
no I don't see any any move to prevent
route takes H for Brooke h takes h form
yeah no spy chicks is it really has made
in that made into probably not yet but
maybe maybe it's made into a moose yeah
I don't see how he avoids made into now
I can just let the clock run down
overstep the time limit
yeah I'm not much happening here yeah
anyway this video will be released a
couple of days before Christmas and what
I can announce is that over the
Christmas days I will do live streams as
I did okay check who cage-free rook
takes actually I will do live streams
just as I did last year I will play some
games they're probably on anh Li chest
this time um I'll take viewer challenges
play against or people coming to the
chat on twitch or Brad and I come on he
was clicked here I mean this is a
serious game of chess um yeah so i will
do i'm live streams have some have some
chats and so on i hope you will all join
in of course i'll make an announcement
in the next couple of days about the
precise dates and times i will try to i
will do more than one show i mean
probably two or three to see that the
various time zones okay with the times
I'll do three is a good number probably
yeah and what is this now you're not now
look no going to let the clock run down
yeah making a fool out of yourself or I
really don't understand the kind of
rationale they're just resign it and
play a new game try to learn from what
you did wrong in this one okay
checkmate so let's see what happened in
this game yeah we had an Italian opening
Italian game and this is an interesting
move order castles it has a couple of
points 1 point is that with the laying
other moves white sometimes can go for a
quick rupee one for example if like
yours here here and now has the idea to
play some ultra-quick d5 and this is not
a great idea because the rook gets to
the e-file now very quickly and this is
an entirely different situation than
with will see three being played like
why it's just a bit quicker than d5 is a
very risky move the second idea of
castles is the move d for he and this
position it looks a bit crazy but it is
an interesting gambit line it is
probably not one hundred percent correct
but it is yeah it's not easy for black
point is that this is not great so
Bishop has to take this is of course
also move that leads to the so called
max Langer I'm goof max lanier tech we
had english yeah max longer attack d5
takes takes check and this is kind of
this kind of this kind of business yeah
it's a full-fledged line pretty pretty
sharp stuff so it normally boils down to
that where white plays Bishop g5 or f
for yahoo iphone as he did now these six
ticks ticks this is an interesting line
I think that black is probably I'm very
okay yeah he made those moves 93 this is
very okay but it's something that I
don't know well so i decided to cop out
with d6 this can transpose to normal
if white now goes here and here or let's
say normal yeah more common lines but
this is of course very logical just
playing like this here white has a very
boring option in taking yeah then I will
take 90 x projects check it and this
kind of thing here black has no problems
but yeah neither has white so it's not
nothing very exciting him if whites
grabs a pawn that is so helpful you gain
a tempo and then take here yeah black is
a little bit more comfortable it's not
nothing great but a little bit okay you
went here and this is an interesting
choice and i don't i don't really
believe in it that much because after
age six you don't want to go back
anywhere here i have none of this looks
very promising here you can even
question if I can take check the pawn
you definitely don't want to take on f6
I mean this position is just great for
black with the two bishops and the
pressure on d for something like this is
downright awful here black has a very
good position yeah and well if you go
here you then have to justify this kind
of this kind of position as i mentioned
detain c5 takes on h4 this this looks
good for black yeah like it sir hoping
for a good play on the G file and
everything is coming out super quickly
age 3 Bishop g4 and so on know that it's
pretty strong so we went with the
sacrifice yeah and as I said this
doesn't work at all yeah the engine
wants to take the Poland before but this
is also a good move yardi 5 going
night h7 is also possible but this is I
think pretty convincing like it's better
developed and it's the one with the
potential attack on the King side NM AP
is up hereford two points ok this was
played yeah I'm just going for the
simple moves maybe there was something
even more powerful are you look FG six
even little bit stronger but still that
is not as a playable position and push
it G for know it sir that leads to a
checkmate in a couple of most going to
stock fish now cannot cannot defend it
check checkmate here we had the made on
the board um yeah deadline with these
six is a good option if you want to
avoid the somewhat weird complications
of the of the d4 gambit move um
theoretically best is to allow the
gambit and and accept it but i'm not a
huge expert i keep forgetting this line
i have looked it up once or twice but i
keep forgetting it so normally i just
play with g6 and i'm happy with the
resulting position so why not do it ok
well thanks for watching